inutile de le nier un jour ou l'autre
nous avons tous rêvé d'être le seigneur
du château
[Musique]
surtout lorsque le quotidien de vos
voisins évoque étrangement une série
télévisée
mais pour jouer au châtelain il ne
suffit pas d'être bien né
il faut aussi avoir la main verte
[Musique]
chaque semaine bazin jules potet
s'occupe de l'entretien du château
familial
c'est son père qui l'a acheté comme ça
sur un coup de tête
c'était il ya 40 ans à l'époque
ce parisien rouler en rolls et selon lui
personne ne voulait de cette immense
demeure construite au 19e siècle pour
avoir un château fort et riche et c'est
vrai que quand je suis arrivé ici
j'étais jeune j'étais beau j'étais riche
et j'étais intelligent il reste plus
grand chose de tout ça car il a un
appétit féroce sur mon compte en banque
il ya toujours quelque chose à réparer
il ya toujours quelque chose à arranger
je suis le spécialiste des toilettes
bouchées des tuiles qui tombe il a du
caractère le châtelain de villersexel il
se soucie peu des honneurs et des
notables n aime pas vraiment qu'on
vienne l'enquiquiner sur ses terres dieu
sait si j'agace dieu sait si les gens
m'aiment et me détestent mais je survis
allègrement et je pense que comme ce
sont les meilleurs qui partait premier
je serais sûrement dans les derniers
depuis deux ans ses bases un jeu l'un
des enfants de la famille qui gère ce
château qui compte des dizaines de
pierres sont nés une structure très
familial on a à peu près cinq employés
la plus grosse charge c'est les salaires
et puis les charges qui sont annexés on
pour être dans le vert ou en tout cas
pas perdre d'argent juste avec sa faux
atteindre cent mille euros
voilà juste pour couvrir les charges
annuelles
alors petit jeu vont commencer est ce
que vous avez remarqué la différence
entre l'aide de gauche celle de droite
et pour gagner un peu d'argent on
organise ici des visites guidées 18
euros par personne pour une petite leçon
d'histoire milieu de la pièce un lustre
en bronze plusieurs centaines de kilos
250 à 300 kg au bas mot j'essaie
d'éviter d'en parler quand je reçois des
gens en visite guidée qui prennent le
petit déjeuner ici parce que tous ces
lustres à l'époque ont eu tendance à
tomber à cause de leur propre poids iam
room to host à et götze romanow come
back to you cas on peut même dormir chez
la femme hypothèques qui propose des
chambres d'hôtes
l'été les touristes étrangers raffolent
de la formule oui c'est vraiment très
beau et très romantique et vous avez
découvert ce château comment par
internet et pour attirer encore plus de
monde
le jeune châtelain sert les prix avec
des nuitées à moins de 100 euros
je considère qu'on est à villersexel
qu'on est en haute saône et que ce qu'on
peut pratiquer au niveau tarif c'est 20
% plus cher qu'un hôtel normal
il y a les visites guidées les chambres
d'hôtes mais aussi des séminaires ou des
vernissages
[Musique]
sans oublier bien sûr les mariages les
journées de base un jules comme de sa
famille sont souvent bien remplie et les
demandes parfois étonnantes
on reçoit un stage de danse que chez
nous depuis qui vient tous les ans
depuis 20 ans et donc aujourd'hui
veulent faire de la danse baroque avec
des verres donc je leur fournis les
verres à pied pour pour faire leurs
danses
[Musique]
mais pour accroître la notoriété du
château
les potters ont accepté d'accueillir un
événement qui aurait fait peur à
n'importe quel châtelain la rencontre
était improbable tant leur univers sont
différents mais le courant est très bien
passé entre monsieur potins et le
musicien francis décamps ne st pas un
festival de rock dans le parc du château
le voilà le projet un peu fou du
claviériste qui fut l'un des fondateurs
du groupe ange
j'ai hésité longuement j'ai hésité
longuement parce que pour moi je voyais
des cailloux des canettes un peu de un
kick et j'étais un peu réservés et si ça
s'est déroulé c'est justement parce que
suivent ça s'est bien passé entre nous
deux ça aurait été un autre et je leur
était pas fait remarquer s'il y aurait
pas eu de château il l'aurait pas fait
non plus depuis quatre ans le château de
villersexel se transforme l'été en
temple du rock progressif
le rendez vous est même devenu le plus
important du genre en france
je suis rentré dans le pas j'ai dit
c'est là c'est dégueulasse ça ya de la
magie
parce que c'est faire un festival c'est
pas amener des gens comme des moutons à
les entasser pour écouter de la musique
et pour partager une soirée avec des
artistes mais ces dix ans des amis dans
un endroit où il ya une magie
[Musique]
beaucoup d'objets différents dans ce
château et ne sut attend beaucoup de
nous je crois qu'il collectionne les
pianos une musique parfois expérimental
qui a même ses vedettes comme steve
hogarth du groupe mari violent ma
chambre est un peu plus loin juste un
kilomètre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le châtelain assistera re mon concert
ces soirées il préfère les passer dans
les salons de ce château qu'il a
patiemment remeubler au fil du temps on
vous a déjà proposé de le racheter le
château
oui on m'a proposé une fois une mallette
avec record millions d'euros dans une
mallette et c'était le premier versement
de trois essais tête ou du cash et je me
pose encore la question maintenant de
savoir pourquoi j'ai dit non si c'est
par peur ou si c'est par morales c'est
vrai que j'ai des raisons de dire non
affective et puis j'ai des raisons que
j'estime logique ses 40 ans de travail
au château de villersexel son pays sans
rien quoi cesser ces voix là et j'ai
bouffé tout mon héritage c'est plusieurs
centaines de mille euros c'est c'est
beaucoup
[Musique]
vous gagnez de l'argent avec un château
je sais pas faudra venir dans 20 ans je
sais pas encore je pense on peut il
gagner de l'argent mais j'ai pas encore
la certitude
depuis 40 ans la famille potet
s'accroche à son rêve et continue de
chérir cette demeure magnifique et
capricieuse qui vous envoûtent la nuit
pour mieux vous faire les poches au
petit matin
[Musique]